remember
actors joined writers on the picket
lines in Los Angeles and New York in a
double strike that has brought the
entertainment industry to a grinding
halt
um Striker Casey Hamilton says one of
her top concerns is artificial
intelligence taking the place of living
actors actors need to be present and be
in the work and so to have that taken
from us is taking away our lifeblood our
resonate
Chris Devlin is pounding the pavement
for better pay and royalties the
mythology is that you know both writers
and actors out here are making big money
and you know living the high life and
pretty much we're just struggling to pay
our rent and and uh pay our bills
Catherine Kim thinks the big movie and
TV studios will soon begin feeling the
pressure we've got the writers and now
the actors I don't know how they're
going to promote all of their summer
Blockbusters for one they're going to be
no red carpets nobody's going to be on a
glossy magazine cover nobody's going to
be on a talk show
the strikes have upended the
entertainment business halting shoots on
scores of films some of the high-profile
films that have stopped production or
are otherwise in limbo on account of the
strike include Avatar 4 gladiator two
Deadpool 3 and a lion king sequel
in New York actors including Jason
Sudeikis the star of streaming TV hit
series Ted lasso and oscar-winning
actress Susan Sarandon picketed outside
Studio offices three
group of actors union members met in
Washington to show their solidarity I
don't think it's
both my likeness and my voice for future
movies without my consent
on the other side of the fight
representatives of studio and streaming
services say the Union's demands are
unrealistic
they say that generous pay increases and
concessions on AI have been offered but
rejected
no further Labor Management negotiations
have been scheduled
both sides are settling in for a work
stoppage that could continue for months
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles